[Applause]
in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us many veterans who served our
country are now in need of someone to
help serve them nearly 38,000 veterans
are homeless and more than 82,000 are in
nursing homes some American families are
stepping in to help and opening up their
homes it's part of an innovative
Department of Veterans Affairs program
chip Reid visited one family and the
veterans living with them on a farm in
Indiana watching Bill Sutton you
wouldn't know the 53 year old combat vet
could walk he got and you're learning to
walk now do not be running soon you'll
be running yeah up and running this
double amputee says because instead of
going into a home he found a home
there's no way I bow to Barry channel
this is where you want to be under the
same roof as the roofing family who've
opened their home and their hearts to
serve those who serve you have how many
children we have six and you have how
many veterans living with you we have
three
that's right six kids all homeschooled
three vets go to have one dog and too
many cows and chickens to count are the
three veterans who live here
like family members who watches cartoons
with them their care also is a family
affair days begin with breakfast
depending on the veteran we may have to
toilet them bathe them dress them shave
them feed them and you're doing that and
also doing it with six kids when we
first got our first veteran after two
days she's like I can't do this really
now we've been doing it over four years
so we're doing good
any regrets maybe we should have just
made the home a little bit bigger troy
bilt this whole new wing on their home
four years ago and do you like it love
it beautiful for the three disabled
veterans this house is an alternative to
a nursing home there are so many
families who aren't ready to put their
loved ones in a nursing home they're not
emotionally ready financially ready and
this gives them an alternative the VA
Zerhouni
to live in private homes for about half
as much as costly nursing home care and
the $2,400 they pay on average each
month helps their host families to is
that one of the best parts about this
that you get to stay home absolutely it
is that's a blessing
and I have my husband working alongside
me the idea came from Troy's family
nearby his brother Todd houses two
veterans who are learning to live with
the loss of a third I'm sure that's hard
when someone's living here and you have
a loss like that are you guys doing okay
VA doctors and nurses make housecalls
and music therapists help keep their
minds sharp bill Sutton says there's
only one thing missing they'd need more
kids they need more kids yeah they have
six already oh it needs at least 23 they
need at least 23 kids yes you have to
open your homes and open your heart to
those veterans it's a sacrifice it's
service but they deserve it deserve a
home and a family who found their own
way to serve for CBS this morning I'm
chip Reid in Greenville Indiana another
reminder I was thinking that - Nora
another reminder there are so many
wonderful people in this country special
mommy hug to Sarah and Troy roofing
that's amazing with six kids that they
would do that I have chills just
listening on story